as you heard my name is Christian and
currently I'm working as a software
engineer in the acute company which one
of the companies that support the cute
project maybe you heard about it later I
will have one slides explain the
motivation behind this talk and why I'm
talking about C++ and Python so first of
all don't worry about the examples or
the slice or whatever just go to that
github repository there is a link to the
slides
and you can get all the source code oh
my god I feel like a star everyone
taking pictures like that you can take
it out on at the end of the talk also is
my kid have usernames you can check it
out it's called unleash the pub CBB ok
so first of all the cute project in
general is a C++ framework huge Pro
framework and with starting to do some
Python stuff you need to have the
mandatory comparison between two
languages first of all the fall we know
that both languages are general purpose
but also you have multi-paradigm you can
do many things with them and then we
start to notice some difference that may
I'm pretty sure that most of you are
aware of dynamically type statically
type compile interpret and then memory
management and about also called
reliability so I know this is kind of a
if we have just raise your hand who is
currently writing C or C++ code ok good
so I I felt your pain too so I know that
sometimes C++ could be complicated but
it's just want to show you that it's not
and you can even make things in Python
better so first of all everyone knows
that python is beautiful I remember the
first time that I typed I've that on
console when I was studying computer
science and it was Wow everything works
but if you think about it I mean C++ is
not so different right I mean you can
write something like maybe you need to
run an external compiler or something
but you achieve the same thing right so
ok
after all C++ is simple it's not because
then you have things like meta
programming and you certain you know
templates over template of and this is
one of the reason that people get scared
of C++ but it was it's not so ugly and
this is some extreme cases of people
with a lot of time that a lot of effort
and try to do these complicated things
like a compile
if but let's go about one of the goodies
a couple of goodies that C++ and the
latest standards being 11 on has I mean
if you're familiar with C or C++ now
there is this amazing auto-type that
kind of detects the variable that you
have which is kind of a similar like a
more dynamic language but not you can
even use some functions and to get the
declarative time of a different variable
to the to the clear another one and
stuff and then again we have the for
loops that with the time it has been
improve it I mean this is kind of the
more dumb old version that we have in
C++ to kind of like own a vector I know
that you can do also with an iterator
too but it's kind of like going element
by element but it's too complicated so
then you can do more fancy things like
this and if you remember the author 1
then you can kind of color it which is
not so complicated you want to set also
if you're a fan of Python lambdas you
can now so also do it in C++ with the
latest standards and so on and so forth
and you can have this for each meant in
handling a nice lambda there to just
serving up some values but most
interesting things about C++ are coming
in my opinion in civil F plus 20 which
is I don't know I have this relationship
with love and hate we see the past 20
there are some things are really nice
and some things that I have no idea why
people is doing it but one of the things
I like is this one so you have this
amount sorry this type of ranges that
you can use now and if you see the 4
they kind of like the type of the 4
there it's kind of similar that can you
you can have their so after all I mean
it's not so crazy different right the
same with a more example I mean I know
that this mod way maybe is the first
line that is commented out but you can
write the function maybe like the second
line that you see there which is also
quite similar what you can achieve in
C++ 20 so after all I mean it's just
adding some semicolon sense yet right so
the idea is that now it's not about like
which language is best but how to make
both languages to to improve each other
and try to collaborate in a more
efficient way so I want to propose now a
new language that is cognizant
but I'll just talk it to an extending
Python with C++ and for this we will go
through a couple of example really
simple ones and the first of who here
didn't know before the conference that
Python was written in C we had some okay
we have some people okay so it is
something that also was kind of shocking
to me because I thought that it was some
black magic assembly stuff but it was
written in C so if you learn some see
you could at the standard and then you
can understand all the things like this
joke for example I know that is really
bad but it's the only job that I have in
this slice but so I'm really sorry but I
didn't to do it so let's take a look at
how we can create an amazing module base
in pure C Python and okay let's go for
it so the first thing that you need to
know is that you just need to see C file
and we will go through these examples
with the most simple thing that I could
think there was a HelloWorld function
that just returns the char star or a
string whatever so I hope that everyone
can read if C if you don't know C or C++
is kind of that you get the idea it's
kind of a function declaration that
returns some message which is hello
Europe -
2019 okay so for building in C++ I will
just sum out
don't be aware it'll be afraid just to
show you so that's all the code that we
are required to create a new Python
module written in C Python which one
function that is just printing hello
world it's not so scary right I mean I
need to confess the first time that I
start to play around with this I was
just copying all this weird structure
that you have around that all these
Weider's has its null null 0 and all the
things you just copy some stuff and it
works so if you were brave enough after
this talk just go to the C Python
directory and play with it and maybe you
can write other sophisticated models
with it so this is the simple case right
and this is just one example one simple
function and we have this so um what's
the motivation behind these cute things
so cute is just a C++ framework that is
like huge and the main one of the main
functionalities was to offer the way of
developing user interface a graphical
user interfaces for people and also cute
implements many of the things that we
have for free in Python in C++ which is
like a lot of instructions for different
classes to interact with more m4
databases or maybe do in command line or
scripting alike in C++ and even other
advanced things a different way of
creating user interfaces action
certification threads all these things
so they are providing a lot of goodies
to the Silver's past world and at some
point the project was but you know what
widget I mean this thing need to be
maybe available other languages so
people started to worry about Python so
maybe you are aware there is already a
set of pining which is really always
called PI cute and this was developed by
a different company some people doing a
lot of work there and this was fantastic
I mean the good project they wanted to
kind of have an official adoption of
these things so they decided so maybe we
can create a new set of bindings and you
know just put it there and see it's a no
problem you know market so people can
decide with use at the moment there but
the same level one is really old and
there's a lot of examples and tutorials
but they are the the cute project at
that point had a couple of options to do
this with this huge c plus web framework
so they could roll a right Rossy Python
they could wrote a sweet I mean maybe
you heard about sick or they could use
boost Python so if you take a look at
this week implementation so which week
and we just just for you to believe me
we have here or difficult function to
understand and the only things that we
need to do for this week is just to
create an interface so this interface is
in that I file that also nothing really
scary or something at the moment so we
have a couple of instructions to build
it I mean we run suite and then we
compile some stuff and then we can just
use a normal simple import the module
and execute it
and then we have the message nothing to
do with boost Python is kind of a
similar story we go there again we have
this simple CPP file with our function
there and then we just need to define
booze by the module the name the name
space and
then we define the function nothing too
scary at the moment right so this was
looking that's really a really nice
solution right I mean we were achieving
the same thing but the problem lied that
many things that we do in C++ need to be
specially treated inside Python for
example ownership of objects if you are
rubbing an interface that is in C++ who
owns the objects some cases will be
Python so in case it would be C++ so you
need to deal with all these things okay
so the option that added at that time
the developer had was okay this use one
of the generator and we can maybe modify
the wrapper generated code so let's take
a look of the code that sweet generates
so just for you to give you an idea so
this is kind of the code that generates
and I will start to go down where in two
percent three percent okay we'll just
page down four five seven two so I
understand it it's a little bit too much
with this small function right so okay
that's all and there is kind of a
motivation to say okay I know that they
need to set up many things to get for
granted and to automate many process and
it's a really smart solution but if you
want to modify this file it will be
invertible I mean you cannot do it so
there was a lot of motivation behind
this C Python and sorry ants week and
boost Python boosts I don't have the
source code from the boost Python here
but the shared libraries roughly the
same size so you can imagine that there
are a lot of black magic there so what
do you say okay they started the
development of this new tool base in
booths at the mo and they said and I was
too heavy let's write our own thing okay
everything was released properly then
there was the project will continue the
development and the good news was that
last year officially was released this
new set of bindings of cute in Python
and in their name of a new project was
called code for Python so maybe you
heard about this or PI site - it was
this all this story behind but ok this
is just a story but what was the
important part - at least in my opinion
how do we do it so this tool that if you
see here in the center ecology bogan -
is kind of like the response for writing
our own
and code generator tool to expose all
this huge C++ framework to Python so
there is a module inside that it kind of
extracts all the API information from
cute base is basing clang of course if
you want to do smart things in serial
class you need to use client then we
have a support type system which is
nothing else than XML file then then you
get wait something's mean we're an XML
file what you can define all these
things that I told you about ownership
or for example what do we do if a
function has a void star argument in
Python we need to have a special or type
or treatment or do some casting or
something around so this to a graph this
type system the information from the
framework and generate some wrapper that
the one that you saw from France week
but of course more reduce and it makes
more sense and it's more clean in my
opinion and then with this we can just
compile it and have a the same Python
module over here so this tool is called
people can the documentation is there
and I don't know what is happening able
to do anything and the slides are coming
ok so the Japanese candies done doesn't
mean anything if there we have some
Japanese speaker there here is just
three words that make no sense but let's
take a look of the token thing okay
so again and we will go first for you to
believe me that we have here the
implementation and we are like cheating
a little bit because of course we are
working with strings from the standard
library then we define complex header
for this which is just that and for this
type system that I just told you it's
nothing else that this so we've had its
ml we said this will be a package called
simple it would have a primitive type
there is a string from standard library
and a hello function after all the the
compiling and stuff we will get
something like this
let's go to bill and it's inside simple
and here you have the moral rapper I
will zoom out just for you sure that I'm
not lying it's long but it's not so long
as the other one so here you have it I
don't wait I don't expect to you to read
the code you just want to show you the
magnitude of the code so at least this
is being code generator matically
generated calling this C++ function and
exposing everything which the Python to
to be able to use it from Python so it's
way shorter that the option that we had
of course this translates into having a
more a light way to hedge share
libraries and you can achieve the same
things so there are other nice options
out there and for this I kind of tend to
recommend people to take a look of all
the solutions that you have out there
because it's unfair to say yeah this is
the best solution no it's not I mean
there are many things that you can
complement to each other I don't know if
you have the chance and or maybe know
one of these ones the last one for
example is the one that the other set of
binding code by cute uses which is
concept pi by xi it also is a really
nice project that appear and the I think
in a couple of years ago even a thing
that to your pythons ago there was also
a talk about 5 and 11 so let's take a
look of like how do you achieve the same
things and with the other options I
think that I am good with the time at
the moment so this is the case of pipe
and 11 so let's open again the file if
you see the motivation here is clearly
from boost Python I mean it's again I
kind of a macro that kind of defines a
module then you have the definition of
the function some documentation and so
and so forth and then you can do the
same thing I mean after you compile it
and everything you have your simple main
that you can achieve the same so it's
kind of like same ideas boost Python but
they are doing way more things and there
is a lot of nice support there that I
encourage you to to check it out CSS
file well this is again not really fair
comparison because see if f5 we had some
talks already that we explained about
this thing it's not kind of like
generating code but it's just kind of
floating something so we
have this is the here this is the code
that is being generated yes so we go to
the simple build and then you have to
have like in line raw a string that
contains the function that we want to
expose and then we just compile this
thing in some share library that we can
easily load from Python so if you check
you check here for example they the main
is the same thing that we were seeing in
the other examples just calling this
nice function in this case we are
casting two strings so and so forth but
it's kind of the same idea but again I
mean it's not like you can write inline
code kind of read here lots of C++ code
to kind of expose in this way the other
option that I had there and see if C FFI
is kind of focus on C or when they
support C 89 and other standard but for
playing with C++ you have a similar idea
which is CBP YY and finally CPP and then
it's kind of the same idea so you take
clear everything like in a string and
then you they have this declaration and
you can use this from the GBL again same
idea and nothing too scary and the last
one is kind of similar it was a sip that
I show you the one that is using in the
PI cute bindings I will just show you
this we have the simple again same idea
but the only difference that they're
required to define a sip file and it's
nothing like else at this base also it's
quite simple I mean you just need to
define the module and then we have some
include and then the the signature of
the function so there are many options
out there to achieve the same thing
right but what's the idea of doing this
right um I have been having some
conversation with people sometimes that
they say i yeah but I mean I use Python
for everything I mean you need C++ can I
say okay what do you use no I do
everything with numpy because it's
amazing in this fashion
it's Python you know and then ice like
yep you know it's written in C it's not
so okay there's even some people that is
not aware that many
the popular libraries out there are
using se las fallas or C so in this case
we have a case of numpy I just download
the source code the first line is all
the Python files that they have that is
not test and then you have the C files
there which is 96 which is I'll still a
lot the things that they are doing and
if you want to maybe refer to a more
their module the case of PI storage is a
little bit more extreme then if you look
there we have so here we have 547 C++
files inside the PI torch because of
course is based in torch and thirties it
was pass so everything is it was placed
inside so it's kind of a good a nice
motivation of using all these tools to
start to write things to improve the
Python we are all here so if we know C
or C++ we kind of kind of have some
responsibility in your hands in our
hands to improve things and one of the
examples that just out of curiosity and
please don't blame me about the things
that I will show you is that simple case
I was helping someone that I was listing
some files in Python and getting old you
know different absolute path and what do
you use their globe right you use or if
you are more like up-to-date person do
you use the path leaf and then also you
have the globe access there so for this
you know the deal I mean writing glove
is things are kind of simple this is a
hard-coded thing just to play with the
recursion thing but you know import love
and then you need to double stars there
and specify if it's recursive not at the
same way which paths leave is kind of
the same idea right and then I thought I
mean let's let's look at the
implementation and see if we can kind of
do something it's more in C++ so the
first simple kink in my mind that in C++
17 maybe you know there is a new
adoption in the C++ standard which is
the more local file system this is based
in the boosts file system so I thought
okay I will just copy paste the hell
we're example there and I will put the
file system
and call to list directories so again
same idea I will just replace the old a
simple and hello and the only difference
is this if there is any easy Python code
available in the audience please forgive
my C Python policies just to show how
simple we can achieve things of course
this is and say if there's memory leaks
there because you when do a pen that
increase the rift counts and I'm not
taking care of anything but just taking
one argument which is the recursive to
see true or false and create an empty
list and then just doing them damn
appends so the magic here from the c++
side is that I am using the filesystem
module I am using C++ 17 and there is
likely some directory generator that you
can kind of do recursively or not and
that's it I mean if you don't know C
Python you just into this is just a
function that will take here some
arguments we create an empty list and
then if it's recursive or not we are
appending well you know how append works
some stuff and then we are returning
this list
nothing else so I thought okay let's see
how this thing was working and then I
wrote a really really simple batch
script because yeah I was growing up
with bash and I thought I will just have
this scenario when I have 1000
directories with 1000 files inside of
each empty files I'm job to list them so
I just create a shell script to measure
this as you can see here they love the
non recursive option which is just
listing the directories inside this fake
environment is 0.05 were suspecting love
to take so long but I think that it
should be something about 20 something
seconds I mean in the meantime I can
tell you that I was aware afraid that
maybe I was using a user beam time and
maybe it's not the proper way of doing
it it's ok there you have it
recursive 33 seconds we were talking
about all these files then I tried a
path live again it was a little bit more
um you know it's lower than the globe
file then the other case is the
recursive way it will be roughly I guess
at the same
I should have had this prepared okay
there you have it
20 seconds and then the first law of
implementation that I have there it's
less than a second I mean I know I'm not
taking care of cash or you know the I
don't know releasing the jewel to use
parallel computer or something fancy
just the simplest thing that you can
think it and there you have it I mean
it's and then I thought maybe it's the
same thing I am doing it wrong so let's
do the same performance and in Python
which you know the time module or
something and after all the twice it was
more or less the same result and it's
not like I want to say yeah this should
be the new glove but this is how easy
you can improve things there and maybe
you are thinking in the next numpy the
name in the next pandas the neck pie
torch or something like that well I will
not wait for the results there but is
roughly the same believe me so yeah this
is a summary it's okay if you cannot
read everything because you can check
the slides afterwards about the version
that you can use the licenses the
compatibility with Python here I just
want to highlight chibok and I think the
thing that I am working with and also
sip because there is something that is
called stable ABI maybe you heard about
it
yes yes similarly a good so this is just
for developers to your release wheels
that are compatible with Python 3.5
onwards I don't need to have different
wheels with different Python persons so
this is really tricky it's just the way
did you create objects are a more
dynamic way but it's really hard and
it's implementing it in those two
options so that you can have information
from the PI sub project you can find me
here also you can check the my social
networks and all their all the
information and the you can just type
make I add some make faster just for you
to know the process of building all this
rubber so you can start playing around
today about it and just as a PSA that
it's always good to support your local
groups so if you at any moment you come
to Berlin I mean we have I think one of
the most amazing Python communities out
there we have pi ladies Python users
Berlin PI Berlin and PI data Berlin so
that's it thank you very much
[Music]